Sound Lab 2.0 builds
on an earlier project
that we'd been working on.
It was essentially four computer
stations in the Music Library
that allowed students to
work on their sound editing
and sound technology projects.
And Sound Lab 2.0 is the bigger
and better version of it.
So after the first
round, we realized
that we were quite interested in
expanding on what worked well,
and we wanted to see sound
technology more integrated
into curricular events.
And so we came up with
a few projects that
would allow this expansion.
The most important part
is to create a website
to let people know
that we exist.
The second most
important part is
to update the equipment,
the computer stations,
buy high-end
recording equipment.
And perhaps the most
significant innovation
is the third part
that allowed us
to organize a regular
series of workshops
that Chris organizes and
runs where he invites
guest speakers who talk
about all sorts of aspects
of working with sound.
And that could be
radio production.
It could be turn-tabling,
so all kinds
all kinds of technological
and creative approaches
that work with sound and
that the students are
very interested in.
One that has been
the most memorable
was we did a workshop about
circuit bending, which
is when you take a cheap
electronic device that
creates sound and it's
typically battery powered.
You take it apart,
reveal the circuit board,
and then you dive right into
the circuitry and rewire it
so it then makes a
new palette of sounds
that you can then manipulate.
Then we brought in Erik Brunvand
from the University of Utah
to teach this, and it
was an interesting way
to create a new sound
device, a new instrument.
But it also was a way to teach
students to empower themselves,
to not be afraid of technology,
to just go right in,
and you can control it.
You can decide what happens.
And he did a really
fascinating lecture
that combined very
technical engineering speak.
He simplified it but was able
to engage with the students.
And then we spent the rest
of the afternoon taking apart
electronic toy dogs,
other Casio keyboards,
the weird random
things that we found
at thrift stores, and a bunch
of toys that he brought in,
kids toys, that we took
apart and made some amazing
sounding instruments.
It was quite a lot of fun.
At the moment, we have
a couple of courses
that use the equipment
from the Sound Lab.
There is a freshman seminar
that my colleague Chris Hasty
teaches on sound tracking,
producing sound, music
and sounds for
pre-existing film clips.
I've been teaching a
course for the last five
years, "The Art of
Listening," that
uses the equipment quite a lot.
The whole course is
arranged around a number
of creative projects,
starting with a mix
tape where we hand out a
cassette tape to the students.
And most of them
have, obviously, never
seen a cassette tape
before and don't really
know what to do with it.
And so we start with
this Jurassic technology.
And then we move through various
aspects of digital editing
toward the final
project, which is
a sound map of sonically
interesting places
around Cambridge.
So they record and
edit their soundscapes,
and then we put them
up on a digital map.
And so over time, we
get historical layers.
Some students and
some TFs have taken
advantage of our "Intro to
Audio Production Workshop."
The focus is on podcasting.
"California in the '60s," which
is a class that's also offered
in the music department,
but other classes
throughout the FAS have
brought in students or faculty
have come in to attend those
workshops, to enable themselves
to then go and teach
how to do podcasting
or then the students can
directly learn how to do it.
So a variety of
people have come in
to use the resource that's
been created with this funding.
And one of the
things that's really
surprised us is the
overwhelming response
that we've received from
all parts of the university.
We've worked with people
from public health.
from the Divinity School,
with the Hutchins Center for
African-American Studies--
History and literature.
--history and literature,
English, lots of anthropology.
But we expected FAS to
be a central focal point,
but it's all the
other schools as well.
So it's really
something that supports
the work in all of Harvard
throughout the schools.
Sure.
So I think, for us, we had
two measures of success.
One was how well we
connected with other parts
of the institution.
And the other was how many
projects the Sound Lab
generated, how the general
interest in the workshop
panned out.
And we're pretty satisfied
on all those fronts.
For us, the big
challenge is to bring
the integration of
sound technology
and sound production forward
with curricular interests.
And you kind of need to--
I think the hardest part is
to convince faculty members
that they can do this
and that you don't need
to start from
scratch and that it's
possible to build those projects
into syllabi and curricular
ideas in interesting ways.